[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Google
cloud next and welcome to dev 2:06
scaling with cloud identity for
customers and partners my name is Mark
Jourdan
I am a product manager in Google cloud
and I literally only think about
identity I'm joined today by my dear
friends and colleagues Pierre and
Francois we'll invite to join me on the
stage in in just a moment but um I'm
gonna take you through a little bit
first
Francois head of IT operations and
Pierre the chief technology officer of
mal Jeff so as I said I'm gonna talk to
you about the way we think of Google
clouds identity platform I'm going to
invite Pierre to talk about mail jet and
then Francois to discuss how they've
implemented identity platform to scale
their global business finally we rounded
out with some questions I encourage you
all to ask questions in the session or
catch us afterwards in the hallway happy
to dive deep are happy to talk more so
identity platform going back to December
last year we announced cloud identity
for customers and partners or CICP as we
endearingly called it as a public beta
and over the last three months or so
we've seen phenomenal traction we've had
thousands of developers literally
thousands of developers come to our
platform and on board for all sorts of
different use cases we've had people
build identity for things so they've had
you know they've gone from credentials
on things out there in the wild to
short-lived tokens that are issued by
our platform being able to interact with
Google cloud platform to sort of push up
analytics push up data get things from
storage we've had people build MDM style
platforms so logging onto Windows and
Macintosh machines and using the the
platform that we've built as the source
for credentials and we've had people
build next-gen intelligence platforms
across Google cloud platform and all of
other Google a set of Google services
and we took this feedback we reveled in
the fact that these customers are really
getting a lot of value out of this
service that we were providing and we
thought to ourselves this
clatter Danny for customers and partners
it can surely do more than what we're
what we're positioning it as as we were
back to the drawing board and I've got
two big announcements today the first
the service is now generally available
and so I encourage even more developers
to start to bring their production
critical workloads to our service and
have this strong foundational platform
the second thing is we're rebranding the
platform as well and so what was CIC P
is now simply known as I Det known as a
dandy platform and with that we're
bringing all of the samples or the SDKs
all the documentation all the things
you'd expect from a platform so you
don't have to build identity you don't
have to think about cryptography we have
all of that covered for you so what is
identity platform and really this is
about taking Google's extensive
knowledge and giving that to you our
developers and to our customers as a
service so you can you know take all the
lessons that Google's learned all the
battle hardening or the stress testing
that we've done over decades hosting
consumer services and build that into
your services so we break it down into a
few different pillars first and foremost
we want to offer you Google grade
authentication so it's based on widely
adopted Google infrastructure we have
eight services with over a billion users
each and you don't get there by learning
a few things about how to manage
identity securely and so as I said
delivering that to our customers is our
number one priority
second we want to give you customizable
open source and open standards so that
you can build on top of it and customize
it with your own look and feel you if
you want your bro your logo displayed
all the way through the login experience
all the way into your application you
should absolutely do it if you want the
color red from start to finish you
should absolutely do that as well so
you'll never see a Google logo Google
login screens or anything like that when
you use this service but we do give you
things like sign-in widgets to enable
you to use some Google's best practices
to help people on board to stop drop-off
to help adoption of your product in your
service we offer broad support for
authentication protocols so Open ID
Connect sam'l or those sort of things we
support out of the box and we give you
Klan SDKs across iOS and
right in web so you have to build
authentication you don't have to think
about how to interact with our API is in
order to get tokens to sign users in and
things like that and that's great for
service modern style applications but we
understand that in many cases you're
probably moving a service to Google
cloud platform or some other platform
and you need back-end SDKs you've got
existing servers you want to be able to
validate tokens you do things in a
secure and trusted environment so we
give you server SDKs across all the
languages you might expect Python go job
up the list goes on now it wouldn't be a
Google product if we didn't deliver you
advanced user security and so with
Google we deliver a cross account
protection is one of the ways that we
help to protect Google accounts and we
deliver that if you build your service
on top of our Danity platform so what
that means is that if a Google account
being an enterprise account a consumer
account whatever it may be is signed in
to any service sitting on top of ID any
platform the service gets a notification
this account is actively under attack
someone's threatening this account and
can log the user out force them to real
thinna Kate ordered the activity in your
logs so you can take action so you can
use Google's intelligence to help
protect all of the applications you're
building on top of this service we're
soon to offer two-factor authentication
to make that even stronger and so we
really want to roll that out and make
sure that we you know first and foremost
deliver things that are important and
meet customers where they are but start
to do revolutionary things and so you
can see some of the the interesting
things we're doing there in some of the
sessions tomorrow around security keys
and other bits and pieces and finally
we're built on Google secure
infrastructure you've probably heard it
a whole lot in the last few hours at
least and you'll hear it a lot more over
the next couple of days but everything
from the chips in the in the bottom of
our servers all the way up to the data
centers and to the api's that are going
to be exposed to your end-users is using
Google secure infrastructure and we want
to deliver this at planet-scale we are a
global service and we hear over and over
from our customers like hey I don't want
to have to spin up a data base in Asia
East and I don't wanna have to spin up a
data base in amia I want this delivered
where my users are one user might be in
one place at one point in somewhere else
somewhere at another point in time and
don't make me have to figure out
architecture and things like that
for it through a global service with CD
ends where the user is with databases
that are local to the user and I don't
know one just buys identity identity is
not sexy
I wanted to integrate with all the
things I'm already using so make it work
with functions login into stackdriver
start to use other services that I'm
familiar with that I'm already using and
help paint this end-to-end solution
throughout the entire entire journey my
users taking and most importantly you're
building a service so that your users
can interact with your business if they
can't login then they can't interact
with your business so it doesn't matter
how great your features are if they if
they can't get through the front door
that's a real problem and we understand
that so we're offering industry-leading
SLA zuv 99.95% and enterprise grade
support so if you're using Google cloud
platform you have one number to call
them they can support you with all the
things that are important in in our
service so it's great for me to wave my
hands around and kind of talk about it
let's let's show you through it so if we
want to flick to the demo this is Google
cloud platform if you're not familiar
with it it's pretty great and in here
I'm gonna go to the marketplace and so
as I said identity platform is generally
available today and so if I want to
unboard to it I can quite simply go to
the marketplace go to identity platform
and simply enable it that's it so once
the service is on-boarded once you're
enabled for this service there's all
sorts of things you can do with it
here's one I prepared earlier so we
support a range of different providers
as I said so you know we support open
set open standards open ID connect and
sam'l a range of different social
providers as well as you know signing in
with what users have emails and
passwords and things as well as
anonymous which I'm just going to pause
on for a second don't ever store
information about a user you don't need
to you you want to help a user you want
to help build a trust in your brand and
help have a user have trust in what
they're getting access to so start lying
as soon as they access your application
you might want to sort of start to start
to remember who they are start to keep
tabs on what they're doing and then over
time as they you know maybe they get to
a check out maybe they want to put their
credit card number in or something like
that at that point then you can step
them up so you can upgrade that
anonymous account that you previously
created it's been collecting
on that user and then turn them into a
paid user a named user or something like
that in the future this is really really
critical to building that trust to build
that progressive profiling sort of chain
and so once users sign in the first time
we then obviously have a representation
of the account now you'll hear from the
male jet team what was really important
to us was you know people have account
systems today we want to interact with
what you have we want to integrate with
you the services you've already got so
you can migrate users with their hash
passwords directly into our service or
you can create brand-new accounts with
sam'l and open ID Connect and there's no
need to create these these will happen
just in time if you so desire
so let's quickly flip to a demo so I can
as I said this is a completely white
labeled service so I can do whatever I
want with it so I might want to choose
to sign in with Google sign in with
Facebook brand this page the way that I
see fit I might also want to brand it
completely differently support things
like sam'l Open ID Connect maybe
integrate with my existing Active
Directory environment and so I'm going
to sign in here and use my super secure
password and we're going to view a JSON
web token back and so in this JSON web
token we're then going to give you sort
of custom claims information about what
we're storing in for that user so that
then you can take that and enter that
into a system downstream you might want
to get access to to something running
inside of Google Cloud maybe a different
cloud anything that's got our SDKs and
it works just fine the one thing that's
critical here is that we also directly
integrate with the anthos announcement
you heard this morning so if you're
looking to modernize your SAS
applications it's really about starting
with a strong identity foundation and so
while you're modernizing you can look to
move in place to a modern identity
solution and kind of go from there sorry
that's the end of the demo
as I said we're generally available
today and without further ado I'd love
to welcome my two presenters to the
stage Francois yeah he'll discuss a
little bit more about Mel jet and it's
used by Danny platform hello everyone so
first of all thank you very much to be
here it's a pleasure to share that
experience with you so far we talked
about the implementation and we
introduced the the project on the
Magette side and I'm sorry for my French
accent okay so the agenda for the
presentation so first of all I'm going
to talk about our backbone or
architecture and then I will talk about
why we talked about the user management
why it's important for us and especially
why we choose a Google for that and on
francois wheeler talked about the
implementation and especially the the
feedbacks we can give to you today and
mainly the big objective is we need to
share our experience with you so there
is a QA session just after so we are we
are emailing an email service provider
we send all over the world more than two
billion email per month we send
marketing and traction or emails and
there is a huge probability that you
have an email we sent to you recently or
at least during the the response the
platform is really key for us regarding
the sending speed which is something
really important especially for the on
the transactional side we also have a
big big marketing ecosystem on top of
the platform and we have a complete set
of API
let's say that all our architecture is
reachable through a play
so this is the global picture of our
architecture as you can see we have
first of all the first feature layer so
that the center networks our velocity be
on top of that we have all the API
ecosystem a private and public as I said
all our let's say Co application are
which both so the API and we have three
ecosystem on top of this and the first
one is the let's say the marketing of a
system with a lot of different features
and applications templating Tommy shown
all you need to send your beautiful
newsletters and so this is the first
ecosystem the second one is the API
ecosystem so you can reach directly on
our functionalities directly so the API
and the third one is the let's say
integration ecosystem which is really
important for us because we have more
and more big current partners then we
have to integrate so you can imagine
that using that kind of architecture we
need a very huge and strong and solid
user management system so what Jesus I
am customer Identity and Access
Management so you probably already know
about that a mark explained that just
before but as a quick remember and
service to manage users let's say user
database it's also a solution to
authenticate users on the platform on
the solution and it's a set of feature
to provide a user experience so marked
out about that we have two step
authentication for example each log SSO
Exeter etc so user management is
everything especially for us why because
we provide services in B to B and B to B
to C so we have to face multiple
multiple user integrations issues while
because each time we have to integrate a
partner we have to take care about the
education and the Identity Management
and at this point all the project are
completely different so we have to
develop
dedicated platform dedicated solution to
a feed on it second topic why it's
really important for us who is regarding
the security the security is really
strategic regarding the the user
management I think it's so quite logical
but we have to take care of this and
also managing as we do now local I am
solution is really complex and requires
multiple skills especially under the dev
side and now probably you face exactly
the same needs honest
we have more and more customer asking
for social logins so it's some single so
we want to provide to our customers and
it's quite complicated when we have to
develop that by ourselves and the last
point why it's important because the
assignor process has to really be fast
and easy otherwise you can lose in terms
of efficiency some figures we got in
majid so more than found what k users
and we have as you can say more than we
a key daily signing so user management
is really critical for us so why we
decided to move to let's say revamp the
solution fault
first because though as I said it will
be strategic for us because we have we
are a SAS platform so we are really
directly concerned by this kind of
solution as I said also we have more and
more partners and having a new partner
on our platform it's really crusty
because we have to develop a dedicated
solution so it's not quite easy and
regarding the time to market it's
absolutely not good so that's why we
will want you to review completely this
solution this architecture we also have
more and more customer asking for a
notification directly on the audio
actory for example we have a big luxury
brand I cannot say the name here but
it's a French one
it starts with OC you will understand so
they really want to connect directly
they are users to our platform without
managing user on password I can
understand in terms of security it's not
good for them so that's why we also have
to provide this kind of service
the last last point but I'm pretty sure
we are all agree on this our set of
chars we're limited it's limited because
we have to develop that internally and
usually it's not the first topic we will
we want to address when we developed a
new project so in terms of a two-factor
authentication we really want to provide
this solution it's it becomes a stunner
now in the web industry we also want to
provide social logins and we will also
need activity logs and audit
capabilities because we are the 27k
certified and in regarding the audits we
face every year it's something within
patent and we are not directly concerned
now but we are thinking about that the
mobile mobile notification it's also
something we want to provide to our
customers so why did we choose Google a
good question it took time first of all
just to decide that we were able to
externalize that solution because it's
really sensitive it's critical so
sometimes it's quite out to externalized
so first we decided to go for an
externalization and then we had to
choose the partner so why Google for
many reasons
so first because we are hosted on the
DCP so it tells and yes we go natively
we looked at the Google solutions also
because there is a Google provides a lot
of functionalities as a mark present it
just before also because it's really
easy to integrate and you will see it
took us less than six months to
integrate IP I did identity pad
sorry not CICP in our solution and it's
scalable which is also something really
important for us we are growing fast so
we need to have natively scalable
solution and also of order the security
I think Google is really strong in terms
of security at least better learners for
sure so that's why also we we decided to
go with Google to to cons let's talk
about that just one minute
the Vonderhaar dependence so you have to
accept that you're linked with Google so
it's something you have to deal with and
it's a you also have to accept to
externalize that kind of solution and
who have a core service in your
architecture based on the external path
solution so it depends on your business
you have to think about that
having the pros and the cons but honor
for our case we definitively decided to
go with Google and we did implementation
very easy way I will say that the we can
talk about that a bit later if you want
to go more into into the details
regarding the decision photo thank you
so regarding the implementation so as I
said we have a lot of different use
cases to integrate customers with
similar user database some what Open ID
connect also I want to use a G suite
account and we still have our own user
database that we manage today with
logins and passwords so when you have to
do everything it's complicated takes
time our to secure it's not really
flexible and if we dig into the details
this is oh it works today the yellow
parts are what we managed directly so
yeah it's a huge ecosystem to manage
it's also out - yeah there is not a lot
of value in to that so it's really art
for us to dedicate developers developing
identity solutions so in this
architecture all the connections with
external directories with partners is
something we wanted to externalize so if
we go to the target architecture in the
target architecture the system is really
much much simpler we just have to
integrate with identity platform SDKs
our user database at Google and create
connectors between our partners and the
Google's authentication system so we
still have to distribute tokens for
partner integrations we still have to
also have some lookups if we want to
integrate with Enterprise directories I
will talk about that later
but still the system will really much
more simpler you have just one SDK on
your web application to integrate and on
our side we also use the REST API to
directly integrate authentic identity
platform admin features so on the client
side we use the web SDK which is super
easy to enter
and we use the REST API so you will see
into the documentation talks a lot about
the SDKs but not a lot about the REST
API so there is a REST API it's the the
features are complete so you can use it
and that's what we choose to do on the
server side for token validation we use
the recipe errors in this project we
choose to first just do a drop-in
replacement of our method notification
system
so only the user password system and add
the other features after this way we
were able to deliver really fast this
project and adding other features is
really simple because it's already
prepared by the identity platform in
terms of Tyler timeline so along this
yearand
like two months this earrin because of
what PR said really a lot of pros and
cons so we had to decide wisely and then
the implementation was really fast
architecture design in January
development in February and March and as
now the product is generally available
we'll be able to to launch we decided to
not launch within the beta period
because this is all policies that now
it's generally available some
implementation tips so when you do
project like that you have to keep in
mind that you have your own data base
and outside it's something like 400k
users to migrate from one system to
another and unfortunately when we choose
several years ago we choose the
proprietary encryption
a Shing system for passwords which is
not supported by Google because a lot of
ashing algorithm available but standard
ones so we had to find a way to migrate
our users without any service
interruption and also resetting
passwords for everybody was not
something we can do so what we decided
to do is to do a two-step migration
first step during a long period we will
collect user passwords when they log to
our system so the workflow is like that
melody to the
authenticates around the current
internal database password is varied we
will generate will sign up the user to
identity platform with this password and
when we will have something like 80% of
our database migrated like that we'll be
able to switch and say to do 20% that
that didn't clog during the migration
phase that say we will have to change a
password so there are a lot of ways to
do that we decided to do that like that
because we don't want it to lose a lot
of users time when they when they log in
in I don't de platform there are quotas
so the quotas are well documented but
you cannot always ask for the power
increase if you generate a lot of users
of synapse there is in the console
something to do that
those are things that's great in
identity platform is logs
so you have activity logs for basically
everything and there are mostly free for
the most part use it a lot it's really
helpful to is the debug it's also
already app full for auditability so as
PR said we are ISO 27 K satisfied we
have to keep a lot of logs certification
so it's really helpful and it's
accessible through if you use Google
Cloud it's really easy to access like
all the other logs for REST API
the docs are be cheated so if I have a
comment and on this product it was
really great to integrate great to
really fast to integrate Doc's are
sometimes a bit up to find so with the
revamp of the name it may be interesting
to consolidate everything but it's yeah
there is a REST API and the docs aria
finally just to show you we revamped the
authentication page so as you can see
we'll have social logins the top of the
page and will probably change a bit this
page when we will integrate the
Federation by removing the password the
password box what we want to do is
provide the seamless experience for our
users
so we'll probably just ask them to put
their email and check in the hoenn
database which federated identity
provider is used by this user before
redirecting him to the right system this
way
we'll be able to either redirect the
users losing for the right identities
ask them for a password in the second
phase so we'll probably have a two-step
authentication phase to provide the
seamless experience but you can also
just put a button like in the inbox demo
to ask for federated identity provider
mark thank you so much so we just did
general availability today and this is
really just the start for us thanks so
much for the mail jet team for sort of
getting on there and giving us feedback
and so we've heard that loud and clear
some of the things that they've said so
we continue to innovate and I'm pretty
excited to show them some of the things
we've got coming out in the near future
but even beyond that we've got so much
more that we want to do and so we offer
strong authentication today how can we
make sonication so strong that you know
users are never impacted by the
authentication experience but they have
the strongest possible authentication
mechanisms and so we're really
passionate about protecting end users
making sure that they have this
beautiful experience and to end into
your application they're only prompted
for authentication when they need to and
when they when they do go through that
it's it's through the strongest
mechanisms possible more extensibility
we are a platform so how can we how can
we deliver even more extensibility
Google can be opinionated about some of
the things that we do but how can we
offer the right solutions for you and
you say well I really like this sort of
these three building blocks together but
I need to put these extra two pieces on
top of it and so we're doing all sorts
of interesting stuff integrating across
Google cloud with some of the
announcements you'll hear this week and
some future announcements to make sure
that you have the right pieces to extend
sort of wherever you want to go whether
it be hybrid environments on pram more
GCP other services and things like that
so we're investing really heavily in our
extensibility story and finally more
integrations as I said there's there's
great integrations with things like
functions stackdriver we're doing a lot
of work at the moment with other parts
of
business that are really interesting and
so once you have a user knowing you uses
identity is extremely valuable and then
being able to sort of track that journey
be able to feed that into dependent
systems be able to take action be able
to understand perform analytics and
things like that these integrations are
really important not from a security
perspective necessarily although they
are valuable but it's really about
getting the most value you possibly can
out of having users access your system
understanding their behaviors and so we
think that's really important so it is a
it is a priced product and pricing kicks
in at general availability we do offer a
pretty a pretty generous free tier if
you do want to get started and get
playing with it and these list prices so
if you do have an account rep please
tell them do it to reach out to me and
happy to have a conversation so as I
demonstrated in in the demo I encourage
you to all go try it the free tier is
really really generous I'm getting give
it a test if you're stoned on board 2gk
egk on pram Sto all those bits and
pieces this is a fantastic service to
help you're on board to that quickly if
you want a Google stack that's going to
work or you know start to start to take
these identities and use them wherever
you have go to service
[Music]